this video is brought to you by
curiositystream
sign up today at curiositystream.com
real science to get free access to
nebula and catch up on real
engineering's logistics of d-day series
in time for the final episode
in 1959 the british medical journal
reported on something that had never
been seen before
several patients with a mysterious
condition something happening
inside their blood that doctors didn't
think was possible historically we've
understood our blood types to be a
constant immovable fact of our genetics
and of our existence
but what these doctors found were
several definitive cases of people with
an
a blood type showing signs of their
blood type changing suddenly having red
blood cells temporarily expressing the b
blood type antigen this acquired b
phenomenon as it's called
was never seen in healthy people only
ever in people with cancer in their
stomach or intestine
or with some other condition where the
integrity of the gastrointestinal wall
was compromised
over time their blood type would return
to normal but scientists were not
entirely sure what had caused it
in 1972 detectives found a dismembered
body in the river thames
during the forensic investigation one
body part recovered was shown to have o
type blood
later however a different part that had
remained in the water for a longer
period was identified as having
b-type blood the blood groups therefore
implied
the two parts were not from the same
individual however
other evidence determined beyond a
shadow of a doubt
that the two parts did belong to each
other this
therefore raised the suspicion that the
second part found had an acquired b-type
blood
what is the common link in these two
strange situations
it's not a change in genetics that's
causing the blood type to change
nor is it an accidental introduction of
a different blood type from somewhere
else
it's the work of bacteria specifically a
certain type of bacterial enzyme
that cleaves or alters certain blood
antigens turning one blood type into
another for the first time scientists
realize that our blood types are not so
immovable after all
this acquired b phenomenon can certainly
raise problems with typing blood for
medicine
or with forensic science but it could
also hold the answer to a very big
problem if blood can accidentally be
transformed from one type to another
can it be done on purpose can we use
this idea to change blood types
in order to create universal donor blood
that is always so desperately needed
every two seconds someone in the u.s
needs blood
but only around 38 percent of the us
population
is eligible to give blood or platelets
and less than ten percent
actually do it and only seven percent of
the population has the so-called
universal donor blood
o negative the red cross reports that on
average it only has about six units of
type o blood available for every one
hundred
000 people but more than twice that is
needed every day
you can start to see the problem here
there is an ever-present need for blood
especially universal donor blood and
only so much available
in a previous video i discussed the
importance of the different blood groups
and the [ __ ] and rh systems the [ __ ]
system is the most important
and your group is determined by the
presence of the antigens a
and b which are carried on the surface
of your red blood cells
you can have type a b a b or o
o meaning you have neither of the a or b
antigens
the [ __ ] group antigens are sugars that
work to recognize
foreign cells in the bloodstream the o
blood type
lacks the a or b antigen and only has
what is known as the h
antigen it's sort of like a blank or
base antigen
the a and b antigens are then attached
to this h
antigen in the a and b blood types and
the only difference between the a
and b blood antigens is a single sugar
at the end of each structure
people with the a antigen on the surface
of their red blood cells will have an
antibody against the b
antigen found on the b type blood cells
and conversely
people with the b antigen will have
antibodies against the a
antigens found on a type blood during
transfusion
if the wrong type of blood is injected
the red blood cells in the injected
blood will be attacked by the antibodies
and the recipient's blood
causing them to clump together or
agglutinate this will result in
hemolysis
or destruction of the red blood cells
which causes
serious illness and can be fatal for the
recipient
the rh or rhesus system works in a
similar way
if you're missing the most important rh
antigens you're considered to have a
negative blood type
rh negative recipients can only receive
rh negative blood
but rh positive recipients can receive
either rh positive or negative blood
and this is how the eight most common
blood types are formed
and because the o negative blood type
does not produce an incompatibility
reaction in any of the eight types
it's considered to be the universal
donor it's extremely valuable in medical
situations
because in a sudden accident there may
not be time to assess a patient's blood
for its type
as they're bleeding out if in doubt o
negative blood will pretty much
always be a safe bet but o negative
blood can be very hard to come by
some solutions to the blood shortage aim
to get more people to donate
others aim to improve the logistics of
blood delivery helping to get it to the
people who need it most
but even if more people donated the
treadmill of supply and demand is still
profoundly difficult to stay on top of
and this is why the idea of creating
universal blood has floated around the
scientific community for decades
if we could turn any type of blood into
oh blood
then many complications in the blood
donation network
could be alleviated but how far are we
from it becoming a reality
in 1982 scientists first experimented
with the idea of turning any of the [ __ ]
blood types
a b or a b into o blood
because the a and b blood types differ
from the o
type in a simple sugar chain scientists
believed that they could convert a
b and a b red blood cells to o type red
blood cells
by removing these extra sugars with an
appropriate enzyme such converted o
red blood cells could then in theory be
used as universal donor blood
this procedure wouldn't affect the rh
status of the blood however
but conversion of a positive and b
positive red blood cells
would yield o positive blood whereas a
negative and b negative red blood cells
would yield o
negative blood at the time of this
experiment there was only one
commercially available enzyme that might
be able to cleave these sugars
alpha galactosidase derived from green
coffee beans
this looked promising to researchers but
the enzyme came with several problems
it required a low ph of 5.7 to do the
conversion
which is not ideal for red blood cells
that prefer a ph of around 7.4
and to do it a huge amount of enzyme was
required
making the process inefficient and not
economical
and most significantly it could only
cleave the b
type antigen not the a this is because
this enzyme can cleave the galactose of
the b antigen
but does nothing to the n acetyl
galactosamine of the a
antigen nonetheless scientists were able
to convert
b-type blood to o blood which was a huge
milestone
these converted blood cells were shown
to have a normal lifespan and to be well
tolerated in the human body
but because only 10 percent of the
population has
b-type blood versus the 46 of the
population that has a type including the
a
antigen this idea would not be viable
until scientists could find an
a cleaving enzyme therefore little more
was heard of this technology for many
years
that is until 2007 determined to find
the missing piece of the puzzle
scientists began the hunt for a brand
new enzyme
and they began to look in the place
where the reports about the acquired b
phenomenon
had first alluded to the world of
microbes
if gut or river bacteria could
accidentally transform blood types
maybe the right enzyme could be found
among the millions of microbes that live
there
thus researchers began digging through 2
500
fungal and bacterial samples looking for
an enzyme that could efficiently cleave
both a and b sugar groups and within
these samples of bacteria an answer was
indeed waiting for them they discovered
two new enzymes within two different
bacteria
one often found in bodies of water and
one found in the human gut
the enzyme found in the gut bacteria
could cleave the b sugar group at a ph
of seven
and the enzyme found in the river
bacteria could cleave the a
sugar group after a 60 minute incubation
with the appropriate enzyme
red blood cells with a b and a b
antigens no longer expressed
any of them they had all been converted
to the universal
donor blood this looked like the answer
that researchers had been looking for
for years but today this technology is
still not in use
something about this process was still
preventing it from moving into clinical
practice
although the enzyme found in river
bacteria could indeed cleave the a
antigen it was still wildly inefficient
the a cleaving enzyme was 30 times less
efficient than the bee cleaving enzyme
60 milligrams of enzyme per unit of red
blood cells was needed to convert
a to o whereas only two milligrams of
enzyme was needed to convert b
to o and this is not a trivial
difference
isolation and purification of enzymes is
a costly process
enzymes need to be optimized for
stability and efficiency
expressed in some unlucky organism in a
massive fermenter
purified to an insane degree and then
packaged handled and shipped
and if the idea is to convert all blood
types to oh blood
even in remote parts of the world the
cost of needing huge amounts of enzyme
would make the whole thing infeasible
the dream of creating a universal blood
was once again
tabled but 16 years later scientists
have become armed with new technology
metagenomic analysis historically to
search for new enzymes
researchers would have to collect
samples of microbes from the environment
and then culture them a method of
multiplying the organisms by letting
them reproduce in the lab
this of course takes a fair amount of
time and effort but with metagenomic
analysis
scientists can assess the genetics of
everything in a sample at once
and look for the desired genes because
of this
researchers were able to screen 20 000
bacterial samples from the human gut
looking for an enzyme that could
efficiently cleave the a antigen
at first they didn't see anything
promising but when they tested
two of the resulting enzymes at once the
a antigen came right off
the two enzymes are a type of
deacetylase and galactoseminidase
and are from a bacteria called
flavonofractor plowtai
when they work together they provide the
solution that has eluded scientists for
years
and only tiny amounts are needed as
little as one milligram per unit of red
blood cells versus the 60 that was
needed in previous studies
their high efficiency means they could
be cost effectively added to the
already existing routines of blood
collection processing and storage
with major implications for the global
blood supply
typing blood could become obsolete and
everyone who donates could become a
universal donor
people with the more rare blood types
won't have to wonder if the right blood
will be available to them
and countless lives could be saved this
breakthrough paper was only published
last year
so time will tell how soon we can see
this in the real world
but there's a lot of reason to be
optimistic for now though
more work is needed to ensure that all
of the a antigens are thoroughly removed
and that the process will not cause any
adverse effects in the recipient
and researchers also need to make sure
the microbial enzymes have not
inadvertently altered anything else on
the red blood cell that could cause
problems
but it looks like this decades-long
quest may be over
and that the reality of oh blood
synthesis is right around the corner
the blood supply chain is a complicated
ever-moving machine
it's a global treadmill that thousands
work tirelessly to stay on top of
and never is that supply chain more
important than in times of war
and examples from the 20th century show
us exactly how true that is
during world war ii the american red
cross flew
almost 200 000 pints of whole blood from
the us to the allied forces in europe
more than 50 000 pints of blood were
needed for the soldiers fighting during
the d-day invasion of normandy alone
and coordinating this was not a trivial
task
as germany tried to conquer the
continent of europe
the allied forces became locked in a war
of force and power yes
but also one of supply chain logistics
and during the invasion of normandy this
contest came to its most
important climax years of planning
hundreds of thousands of men
thousands of ships tanks and trucks
hundreds of gliders and airborne troops
all working together to pull off the
largest amphibious invasion in military
history
an invasion that would change the course
of history forever
if you're interested in how the allies
were able to coordinate such a massive
military effort
then you should catch up on the
logistics of d-day series made by our
other channel real engineering
available exclusively on nebula it's a
multi-part series with episodes about
the logistics of close air support
fuel supply deception tactics and more
the final episode in the series will be
released soon
detailing the famed truck convoy the red
ball express
that supplied allied forces moving
quickly through europe after breaking
out from the d-day beaches in normandy
this original series is available on
nebula which is the streaming
platform made by me and several other
educational youtube content creators
it's a place where we can upload our
videos ad free
and a place where we can experiment with
new sometimes controversial content
that wouldn't work on youtube there are
long form documentaries by creators like
wendover productions
original series by creators like tom
scott and collaborative series
like working titles that are created by
dozens of different creators together
so to watch the final episode of the
logistics of d-day series
and to catch up on all the past episodes
the best way to sign up to nebula is
with the bundle deal we've made with
curiosity stream
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with thousands of high
budget documentaries about everything
from aviation
physics space and nature it alone is a
great way to learn about all of your
favorite subjects
but now curiosity stream has partnered
with us to offer an
incredible deal by signing up to
curiositystream you now
also get a subscription to nebula for
just 14.79 for the entire year
by going to curiositystream.com real
science
by signing up to this deal you are
greatly supporting this channel
and all of your favorite educational
content creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
you